[Music]
okay everybody so this is my spoiler
review of the first three episodes of
nine perfect strangers make sure you
watch all three episodes before you
watch this review and then come back
from some spoilers also just please no
book spoilers in the comments i'm not
gonna be talking about the book at all
that this is based on so please leave
that for elsewhere so we can all enjoy
this as a new experience so this show is
directed every single episode by
jonathan levine who directed movies like
50 50 and the night before long shot the
writing duties are split up a bit which
is a little disappointing because i kind
of want to see the showrunner here david
e kelly who's brought us big little eyes
the undoing to kind of take helm on
writing here he only does i think an
episode or two but again like that big
little eyes connection with nicole
kidman with him being the showrunner
again but also that also being based off
a book by the same author of leanne
moriarty who wrote the book this is
based off nine perfect strangers so i do
like that the show opens up with this
shot of a blender and you're seeing
these smoothies being made or cocktails
everyone call it it's nicely called back
later in the first episode to how she's
picking these people masha and how she
has to kind of find and curate what she
wants we don't know what the cocktail
the other day's gonna be in the show
we'll probably find out by the end but i
thought that worked well i think masha
had a great intro as a character in
meeting francis who i would argue is the
story's point of view we get the most
from our main characters and we see her
at her weakest moment this is a good
scene by musa mccarthy and it makes
sense because it's leading into what
we're gonna see with masha she's just
jesus figure she's this healer for all
these broken people what i liked about
the first episode was it wasn't shying
away from letting you know that
something is off right away that we knew
this from seeing the trailer we know
what we're signing up for and they don't
make it like oh we're gonna wait a
couple episodes to reveal that
something's off with this place they
make it known and kind of get through
that point fast which i appreciate
they're playing a little smart for their
audience here which is good i'm also
very excited to see nicole kidman in
this role of masha because it's a
different role for her than recently
where she's you know the complaint's
kind of been she's been playing similar
characters like in the undoing and big
little eyes that it's nice to see her
kind of play this antagonist mysterious
character now right off the bat you're
seeing just an amazing performance from
michael shannon he always delivers but
even in this first episode of standout
scene with another great actress and
samara weaving and her husband ben here
and they're in this hot tub scene and
all of a sudden you're seeing how well
michael shan's bringing this character
to the screen how complicated his
character is and how likable his
character is of napoleon so we get
little information about masha's
backstory here that she was someone who
overworked she wasn't the friendliest
person in her past life but she was shot
came back to life and it's like she
changed her life almost dying and it
reminds me a little bit of the jigsaw
killer from saw that it's this character
that learns something through near death
and is trying to change people from what
they learned and show them what they
kind of went through and have an
awakening themselves that they're
sharing and it's like with lines where
she's like you will all have come to die
i will bring you back there can be birth
and death tragedy can be a blessing so
that's where that connection comes from
of like kind of like the jigsaw killer
as a pop falls behind my head where
there's a really good hook in this
episode is when someone says to masha do
you mean to [ __ ] with us like this and
she says this is trink william i mean to
[ __ ] with all of you so it's a nice hook
it brings the intrigue to the show
what's gonna make this different what's
tricky about a show like this though is
introducing this many characters
especially unlimited series so we're
gonna have limited time with them it's
like an avengers amount of characters
were kind of trying to slowly learn
about all their information and it is
always a challenge with all these
different point of views but i think
they do a good job in the first episode
of kind of laying on the groundwork and
getting what we need to know to advance
the story so i'm going to give the
premiere an 8.9 i think it's enough of a
hook and it gets you excited for what's
to come so with the second episode
things started to take a dip down for me
here in quality i think this is where
pacing started to feel really off and
that continues to episode three that
it's bizarre how there is no flow to
this show there's not like a natural
rhythm and it feels like scenes are kind
of patched together and there was a
surprising poorly acted scene for me by
muslim mccarthy when we're seeing a
little flashback of her when she's
finding out about this boy in her life
dying in an accident and something just
seemed like it was mailing in from her
which is unusual for her and some of the
flashback effects they do here like the
blurry effect felt like a hallmark movie
effect so there is some weird tonal
issues and i think that comes to
jonathan levine being the director of
each episode because he does stuff
that's more sappy you know he does these
romantic comedies and he's not really
laying into the thriller drama part we
were kind of sold on this i think there
should be more of that and he's going a
little more towards this is us territory
which is frustrating but let me get more
into that but there's an important line
by francis was mccarthy's character at
their breakfast scene where she's like
identifying your hump and hurling
yourself over it is the essence of life
so that's one of the messages this show
is kind of starting to get at and we're
seeing these broken people trying to do
that here together we also see that this
character of yao is in this kind of
relationship with mash and he's the one
who saved her life but there's like a
jealousy they say with delilah there in
that relationship so they kind of set
that patrick of about the three workers
really have going on and you clearly see
in these first three episodes of delilah
who's played by this great up and coming
actress tiffany boone that she's the one
who's the voice of reason when masha is
kind of clearly on for her own gains and
her own intentions we don't know all
about delilah kind of brings her a
little bit back to earth and it's kind
of just saying what the audience is
feeling and most realistic character in
the show i did like this scene when they
had the exercise of burying yourself in
a ditch i thought it was really good
writing especially when francis was
talking about no one's going to care
when i die facing death and that
practice of rebirth here when they come
up from the ground and you could see
even the toughest people like tony here
who's hard to break he even goes back
and practices himself so it's kind of
working on him now where the show i
think's been the best so far is the one
on one scenes with masha and someone at
the resort so you see that here with her
and jessica played by samara weaving
who's excellent and you know they're
talking about her not being seen that
she thinks about instagram likes all the
time and not really what would happen
with her family if she died but about
how people would talk about her when she
died but masha sees right through this
and says the real reason she's here
though is because you know her husband
doesn't love her but they throw in
little dialogue here to learn more about
all our characters and you see with
regina paul's character of carmel she
did makeup in the past on broadway but
gave it up for her kids so they give you
little things but you want a little more
but again this is the challenge of
having so many characters and where i
got annoyed about this episode is this
is where we hit like a wall and that
happens we got to meet too much comic
relief here with francis and tony in
these two scenes in the pool i think we
only needed one comic relief scene but
they should have left the scene with
tony yelling at her and then jumping in
the pool in a little fight but then they
do another scene with the whole grape
joke and him trying to throw a griper
that almost kills her but this at that
point felt like it was really killing
the momentum of the episode and what we
had built from the first episode and it
felt like a deleted scene watching this
so i wish they would just trim the fat a
little more here you could have
literally cut right to the policy with
francis and tony after the first comic
relief moment with them in the pool not
back-to-back comic scenes that was just
too much and when i'm talking about that
paul scene that's where the important is
where francis is telling him he fell in
love with this man paul line what a fake
child fake illness and she kind of even
as upset she was she liked that time of
thinking she was seriously loved now
where i think this story in these first
episodes working the best is with this
family here with michael shannon's
family and especially his wife heather
who she's thinking about jumping on this
cliff she's at a breaking point this is
terrifying especially because it's in
front of her family and you know you'll
see delilah is really the one who saves
her here and heather this is her rock
bottom but she's the one really going to
see an awakening start first the next
episode so i think they did really well
even with heather and michael shannon's
character of napoleon their stories in
particular in his first three episodes
what i did think was odd was at the end
of this episode they set up that francis
had her one-on-one with masha but
francis wants to leave and masha's
begging one more day they cut off as the
hook that matches take this next step to
keep someone like francis they couldn't
lose any of these guests that they were
important but they never really touched
base episode three about masha's state
of mind and that urgency to leave and
why she's officially staying that i
thought was a missed jump and they kind
of skipped it in episode three which
we'll get to i do want to say something
i found silly on the first episodes and
that's with the character of zoe played
by grace van patten who i've interviewed
in the past checked that interview out
on my channel she's awesome great
actress i'm happy she's getting bigger
roles now but i thought with her
character the first two episodes every
scene ended with her kind of going in a
tantrum but that wasn't the funny part
the funny part was that it always ended
with her just running off screen
somewhere like every single time that i
got silly it's like okay there she goes
again running away upset so that got
repetitive they could have kind of
changed how they presented that and that
to me is part of the directing issues i
have with this show and i want to get
into that because then i i noticed a lot
of directing cinematography not like in
episode three but we'll hold on that for
a second but what was good about episode
two had another good cliffhanger because
masha's taking that initiative like we
need to step up to the next protocol
early because we don't want to lose
these people and you see even yao and
delilah are hesitant to this so it
leaves you you know excited for what's
to come what is masha's plan here but
again this episode is where i started
seeing that the pace was really slowing
down there's a lot of reflecting talking
almost too much that you can kind of get
bored watching it and again it's
starting for that weight of so many
characters and it doesn't handle as well
as i thought episode 1 did so i'm giving
this one a 7.4 but i'm still intrigued
at this point so knowing they released
the first three episodes i'm like okay
maybe episode three is going to be like
the banger that we kind of need at this
point especially in a limited series to
keep people into it but i don't feel
like we really got that so right off the
bat with episode three there's some
weird choices of character here that i
didn't really buy the first one being
that this character played by luke evans
of lars who's definitely the most
underwritten so far but that's probably
again give his character more mystery
he's just calling randomly out ben and
jessica for tension that they're having
for some reason he brings us up and it's
not clear why he just does that out of
the blue so that felt like it was just
random to get the scene going and then
even carmel lunging for lars after he
says she terrifies him there's a lot of
forced fighting i feel like and they're
trying to make it funny that way too and
it does have funny moments in particular
michael shannon again because he's just
crushing it comically and dramatically
he's you know versatile in that way but
again a lot of it feels kind of forced
in and to get those moments like okay we
just need to get this scene to get to
carmel launching at lars but we don't
even really get that much payoff for
that later on the episode anyway what
also felt silly right is that this
character tony is getting a lot of
screen time maybe a little too much with
the cassettes around him it's no offense
to the actor he's great but i feel like
he's getting the most screen time right
now and i'd like to see more of some of
these other stars we got here that we're
all kind of signing up to watch but it
felt a little silly here when we get his
flashbacks of his football days because
we'll find out he used to be a tight end
for the 49ers but in these flashback
shots they got i know it's hard with
budget and covid but it looks like he's
playing on a high school football field
you know this looks like friday night
lights here and he's supposed to be a
professional nfl player but the point of
it is we're learning that he had this
basically career ending injury and he's
hooked to painkillers so he's
withdrawing through this episode as it
seems like they're bringing down his
dosage what i did like though about this
episode was that we had an actually
really effective comic relief scene to
me was with the potato sack race and
it's because of regina hall here and
samara weaving's characters budding
heads throughout the episode but when
they were racing i loved once tomorrow
evening just starts doing a cartwheel i
thought that was great so like i'm
talking about the best parts of the show
are the 101s the best one-on-one yet and
probably the best scene of this show yet
is any of the moments with michael
shannon nicole kidman together and he's
talking about his son zach we learned
more about zach through him and his 101
that he committed suicide so it's a very
darker turn here and he's looking at
like we're the masters of our own fate
and zach chose his own fate so he does
say a lot of things that it seems like
him and masha are eye to eye on just
beliefs and kind of looking inward and
taking control of what you can but when
she tries to go the next step with him
about his son he resists and we get this
interesting moment where when he
meditates he envisions it seems like
maybe a child version of himself and
then another child appears a long hair
and he looks like he's like hammering a
fish or something with a log so i don't
know what that's all about but it's
something maybe if you leave down your
theories on that again no book spoilers
no cheating but where i said this is
like the most disappointing about this
show is there is just no flow to this
show it's all over the place pacing wise
that you really feel here in the skinny
dipping scene cut between the other guy
group on their hike and they're looking
for food but you know there's some weird
camera choices that's when ben's opening
up about the lotto that he won and it's
like this intense you know out of focus
shot behind him i don't understand the
logic behind that because then it cuts
to when the girls are in the hot tub and
samara weaving's character jessica when
she's telling about her self-esteem
issues they just decide to do this
really shaky camera half her head's cut
off and it just doesn't feel like it's
serving the purpose of getting us into
the mindset of the character correctly
it just feels odd like this doesn't
match what it's supposed to be conveying
so that is really strange to me and
that's the tough thing about the show
because you have so many characters but
you just see little dialogue of people
butting heads all the time that's where
it's coming like big old lies but
bigelow lies i think just does it better
because everything's serving a little
more of a purpose doesn't feel forced in
but right now because we're in the same
location and all these characters it
feels more forced in which i think can
be frustrating to watch so where this
ties around is when all these guys are
hungry they see the billy goat that
we've been set up that masha loves right
what annoyed the hell out of me was the
character of yao here who we know really
likes masha he knows that billy that's
important to her he has zero resistance
to tony running after and killing this
thing and if you want to argue okay he
hesitated you know he couldn't run after
tony he wasn't gonna catch him whatever
but even when they're coming back and
he's carrying it it's no point does he
say hey maybe you shouldn't show masha
that or maybe we shouldn't bring this
here it just made no sense for yao's
character especially because then you're
gonna show yao saying he's sorry that he
didn't do anything to her like admitting
it but it still doesn't make sense
bizarre especially he's apologizing at
that okay so why did you do it in the
first place like no reaction at all so
weird i just didn't buy it but there's a
lot of reflective talking here that's
not the greatest writings it's just
saying stuff we know like when lars says
delilah everybody seems a bit different
today and then even masha says many
truths today revealed it's like yes
we've seen this you know it's a lot of
just telling us what we've seen already
which again slows paces up arguably the
best moment of show so far is when
michael shannon has his monologue about
actually the reveal that he killed the
billy goat he quotes a bible verse which
again i'm starting to say is cliche like
every show is doing the bible verse
thing in movies forever i'm getting
really sick of it it's always some
random verse that fits the theme like
he's saying with leviticus but it still
works that's just my personal preference
but he's talking about suicide of his
son and that unintentional sin which is
referenced in the bible and why you
sacrifice a goat when you realize this
and that's what he's feeling and it's
coming out now about why he slept in
through that alarm that day his son
killed himself and he thinks if he'd
gotten up like he usually does wake him
up it wouldn't have happened because he
believes his son was impulsive and that
mostly suicides are impulsive and he's
bringing up stats how people the moment
before they die you know a lot of them
are like why am i doing this so he
really feels that guilt and it's coming
out he's talking about it and that
feeling of unintentional sin that he
should have gotten up you know but you
see heather likes to see this this is
growth by her husband and growth for the
character as i'm saying their is kind of
working the best at this point and it's
just great acting by michael shannon
here like unbelievable but man that
writing with heather just out of nowhere
have you been medicating us like just i
don't think there was even enough for
her to say that yet like sure you know
she sees you know her husband's acting
differently people talk about everyone's
acting weird but i don't know it's it's
just such a basic thing to say and it's
not a great twist to make the hook for
the first three episodes out like wow
what a shocker you know we've seen this
a billion times so that was frustrating
too a little bit of a letdown that
wasn't a great hook to me it's like okay
it's the most predictable reveal you can
have so it's tough because that episode
was my least favorite even though
there's a great moment with michael
shannon in it the rest to me was just a
mess so i'm gonna give this one a seven
but that's bumped up a little bit again
by that last monologue i still have
faith in this show i'm still excited i'm
gonna obviously be reviewing every
episode but i would be lying if i said i
wasn't disappointed by these first three
episodes i did like the premiere a lot
but the next two really just dropped the
ball for me i just hope it picks up and
again we can't feel like we're wasting
potentially with this great cast it's
great environment we're in and it just
feels like it's not really well thought
out right now and put in a cohesive
manner that makes it exciting and
interesting and it needs to lean more
into that drama and thriller that we've
been sold here it's kind of annoying
even like what i'm talking about this is
us vibe that happens even in michael
shannon's dialogue where i don't think
you need to add that this is us music
behind him it's like oh it's just like
just leave it out it doesn't help so i
get frustrated with that but again i
still think there's a high ceiling here
for the show and it should pick up
hopefully but it's a limited series so
it's like come on let's go we're already
three down let's get cooking now let's
give me something i haven't seen before
use this talent you have here and get us
hooked okay that's what we're waiting
for but let me know what you thought of
it down below i'd love to hear your
thoughts i read every comment try to
respond as many as i can please make
sure to subscribe so you don't miss one
of my reviews of nine perfect strangers
i also do celebrity interviews as well
so you want to check that out please
follow me at steve arley's show on
twitter and instagram for more of me and
if you really love what i do here i'd
really appreciate if you sign up to be a
member you can get exclusive live
streams that i do that you'll be a part
of and it will help me do this full time
one day and live my dream and give you
guys more videos so we really appreciate
it until next time have a great day